hello recheck nation Greg Alva here and
I'm John home fries guys do you remember
the year 1922 Stephen King sure does
Stephen King has a lot of adaptations
this year this is also Stephen King yeah
you know that no this is a Stephen King
another Netflix one you know we just
need more Stephen King do Netflix had
one now who who had one letter like six
in the major movie theaters so this is
another one on Netflix no this yeah does
Gerald's the other one yeah every once
in a while one of your adaptations is
great and then we make more yeah I feel
like we're just gonna do each one
multiple times until it turns out great
yeah and then once it turns out great
that we remake it but like the pressures
off Amen sister now do you do
[Music]
and so was my wife behind
[Music]
[Music]
any kids
Yeah right what would that be crazy
[Music]
Wow
[Music]
[Music]
oh man there's a man
[Music]
that looks great looks really cool I
feel like I feel like the Stephen King
period peace movies look awesome and
it's the monitor day ones really like I
don't know about this yeah that looks
surprisingly good it looks amazing every
time a Netflix movie looks incredible
I'm always conflicted cause I'm like
good on Netflix wish this was in the
theater yeah like Chris Nolan trains
yeah yeah because that looks incredible
man Thomas James this is like a third
King movie he was in dreamcatcher and he
did that one in the store the mist mist
you he must love the king he must love
Stephen King or he must just have great
luck yeah I think Stephen King is really
good at the contained environment
stories is all taking place in this
secluded like ranch farm it's the
wedding farm like a farm it's not quite
I don't know what exactly separates a
farm from a ranch but it looks like they
were more Agron I mean the contained
environment aspect looks really intense
I was like whoa killed his wife kind of
a spoiler but then I like seeing the
psychological horror that's playing in
like oh is it real is is he really being
haunted by something or this is mine
kind of messing with him over the
horrible thing he did yeah yeah I don't
I don't know the novella but I've read
some Edgar Allan Poe before and that it
really reminded me of Poe the way it's
always about like somebody who gives in
to a perverse indulgence and then is
just haunted by it to the point that
they finally break they crack they crack
or they find a way to get themselves
killed baby yeah and this reminded me a
lot of that and and the thing is to
before he even gets the part where I
killed my wife and attention I was
thinking like especially for the kids
yeah this is only a trailer and I can
already feel how palpable this must be
for the Sun character especially because
he's caught between these two yeah well
you know this looks like a character
piece a psychological horror movie with
whatever the word is you bought use King
isms yeah yeah the ranch it doesn't feel
like it's gonna be as weird ya know go
Stephen King is known for being a little
weird for some subtle King yeah yeah
yeah and it wasn't about like a short
story oh I could probably read that yeah
I did read 1409 1808 read that book read
that novella the secret window novella
there you go yeah see you're you're
reading a Thomas Jane to like I'm just
happy to see him a leading something
like this and be he looks like he's
doing a terrific job he's great at the
dark girls the first movie I saw him in
ever was Boogie Nights yeah and even
like looking at the Punisher movie yeah
everyone everyone was like punch movie
sucks but Thomas James good and I liked
him a lot in the mist I think it's the
darker roles where this guy really
excels and he clearly drew a lot a
weight to play this role to really fit
into the time period yeah when he first
showed up I was like oh that's Thomas
yeah which is cool I like that he's
throwing himself into this role you know
this looks fantastic it looks scary the
imagery is beautiful I feel like it's
gonna escalate in a nice fashion yeah it
feels like a real tension thriller not
heavy on jump-scare some creepy imagery
here and there and I also like period
pieces that are horror films you know
those seem to work really well nowadays
and it's to this trailers credit that I
was not once reminded of Annabelle
creation or we do yeah I feel bad for
Annabelle because the second that
trailer dropped I was like oh like we'd
do an you know a period especially like
dustbowl style horror is I'm glad I
wasn't reminded of that and also just
hats off to I almost said Thomas
Middleditch but that would be Zach Hill
yeah because I don't I am NOT from
anyway with the students work but at
least this sample here I am very
enthused I'm excited to see what's going
on here the MU is only an hour and 40
minutes I can't watch that rope really
[Music]
now I'm wondering which one's it gonna
be as Gerald's gamer is 1922 this one
day Oh easily
Gerald's game doesn't look that great to
me this looks really good yeah watch the
every other King movies gonna be great I
haven't seen Geralt Hamm so who knows
really that's good too anyway guys
thanks for sending that hour away that
was a delightful surprise you can
subscribe to the real resource click
that notification bell follow dat John
Humphrey on Twitter and Instagram and go
check out our patreon become a patron
eject today putting plenty of content
over there as well feed it